all right what's going on this is Sam
we've got an awesome episode today we
have Andrew Wilkinson on the Pod Andrew
is one of our good buddies Andrew owns
this company called tiny tiny basically
started as like this agency that made a
bunch of profit and he took those profit
and he's bought like 18 or 20 different
companies and he took tiny public I
think today it's trading in the $600
million market cap so he's got like a
really good perspective on what's going
on in life um during this episode I
think it's the the like with 20 minutes
left in the episode he's actually said
something that I'm I'm sitting here
taking notes it's going to change my
business it's about the this thing
called The Profit first uh mentality and
he goes in in depth on how much money he
leaves in each business and how the CEOs
are able to operate him it's really
insightful stuff that I haven't really
heard him talk about before and then
also Andrew is interesting to me because
Andrew is my close friend but he's very
wealthy and I get to ask him all types
of questions uh kind of like behind
the-scenes stuff on how he spends his
money he talks about how he's now a
patient of PETA who's this famous doctor
and how much he's spending on that and
and and the outcome of that I find it
very interesting he talks about shooting
his shot with his hero so he's done
business with guys like Bill Amman who's
a you know worth 10 or2 billion is a
hedge fun guy and he talks about how he
met Charlie Munger who's uh Warren
Buffett's partner and so there's really
interesting insights on a how he lives
his life but how he got in the doors
that he did when he was still up and
coming really fascinating so this is the
episode with Andrew Wilkinson let me
know what you guys think you can hit me
up on Twitter the S par and let me know
if you enjoyed
[Music]
it
all right what's up we got the man Here
Andrew Wilkinson fan favorite guest of
the Pod um welcome Andrew how's how's it
how's it going hey guys I'm good so you
gave us like a list of like ideas and
things that you're kind of messing with
but you have this thing on here about
sexy versus non-sexy things and you're
like the things that everyone loves on
the outside they're the hardest ways to
make a living and so you you said here
that I didn't know this I I or maybe I
did I knew you owned a bakery is you
said you own a deli and a bakery is that
two separate things or is it one thing
no that's combined that's one and it's a
pain in the butt total pain in the ass
so yeah um been thinking about this a
lot lately because I think when you talk
to young entrepreneurs they they always
want to do something sexy and I was like
that too like I was a product CEO right
you think every CEO kind of has their
thing and for me it was making great
products so when I was running software
companies and stuff I'd always be
thinking oh when we release this new
feature that's when everything will take
off or uh you know when we get this
partnership or you know whatever big
announcements I think flashy but one of
the things I've realized after running a
company for like 20 years is it's really
not the sexy stuff that pays off um you
know for example like we have a bunch of
companies um and you know one increased
prices 30% after not increasing prices
for 5 years they Mass massively grew
profits right that took 10 minutes a
little bit of planning um and that paid
off big um you know one significantly
reduced shipping cost by sizing down
packaging um you know another realized
hey we've got insane SEO on certain
keywords and now we can drive affiliate
Revenue uh you know one had a bunch of
customer gift card deposits and they
were like oh [__] we can invest these in
t bills and make 5% makes 500 Grand a
year of just pure profit I just love
these boring things like that and I've
realized that it's kind of sad like you
know I grew up being like Oh yeah I want
to be the next Steve Jobs or James Dyson
or something but the things I'm actually
good at are these really really boring I
call them like lever pulls you get in
you pull a lever and revenue or earnings
just grows you know by X
per. this data is wrong every freaking
time have you heard of
HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated W I can
see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a task
from 3 days ago I totally
missed HP spot grow
better you know the good thing about
that is that the older you get the more
like appealing those get and so for
example like this also is just in life
like you know I've never seen a couch I
don't like you know the older I get I'm
just like yeah it'd be nice to sit right
now and I feel like the same thing
happens in business where I used to
think I wanted to pull off some like
awesome feat of like creativity and hard
work and I actually very rarely want to
do that there's times but most of the
time I'm like oh what's the simplest
thing I could do that will just make
this work better and you were the king
of that you you were the king of that
you you owned a video streaming startup
that were you were like to the moon or
nowhere uh and you spent like five years
or four years doing it I mean building
crazy computer vision features and all
this stuff even before AI became like
you know really big and and the reality
was like we had this other business
called Birthday alarm birthday alarm was
like a reminder of it's your friend's
birthday today and it would send them a
Cheesy e-card you know if you pay $9 a
year and that business had been printing
cash millions of dollars every year for
like 15 plus years I think it started in
2001 and I'm this was like I was working
on it like in 2016 2018 so like you know
18 years later and and um we we were
like you at one point we finally got our
senses and we were like why don't we
make birthday alarm like a little bit
better like uh it pays all the bills we
could just improve it right and even
then the team was like list of ideas
rewrite the whole thing in the new like
you know make it rewrite it in
JavaScript oh it's written in this old
like language because that's what was
hot in in 2001 we got to rewrite the
whole thing and then when we do that
we'll be able to make it so much cooler
we'll add these new features we'll
redesign it we redesigned it our
designer spent mockup after mockup on
like making it cleaner and more
minimalist and more cool or whatever and
I tell you what after a year of doing
all that [__] there was really only two
things that made a difference um number
one we raised prices uh so you raise
prices by 30% exactly what you said
Andrew because the prices hadn't gone up
in 15 years you just delete the zero and
the $20 a month and change that to a
five so it's 25 a month exactly and then
the second thing was
um we implemented stripe instead of the
old payments platform because stripe had
a feature where if somebody's credit
card expires and they get a new one like
an they you know their credit card
company gives them a new one it would
mess up your subscription and there the
stripe has a feature for for 25 cents
they would just update it with the new
card automatically without the user
having to C type anything in and that
one that like one feature is like a you
know seven figure feature that took
honestly no work on we just check a box
on on stripe to be like yeah we want
that we'll pay the quarter for every
time you do that and um you know we made
like an extra million dollars a year of
profit just off of that one thing
basically and uh it was a big lesson
learned of like you know the the link
between effort and result is uh so much
more disconnected than you think and uh
the more mature you get the more you
realize like you should just work
backwards from what's actually going to
work not like what's the cool or or
difficult thing to do these these things
too they're so often they one day of
work right like we had a similar thing
we had this um invoicing software about
10 years ago called Ballpark and um it
was the first SAS uh product that we
built and we realized we were doing like
I think a100 million of payment volume
through the credit card processing so
you know I send Sam an invoice for 10
grand and he has the option to pay on
credit card and we just marked it up too
and I think that was worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars to us and I
remember it was like 10 minutes for me I
was like going through stripe and
realized there's this setting and I
checked a box and suddenly we make way
more money so I think um this stuff is
super powerful and I mean like just to
tell to like give an example so um you
know Sam mentioned so I own like a deli
and a bakery and when I was a kid there
was this uh Bakery down at the end of my
street that I would always go to on the
weekends I'd go and get a croissant and
have a coffee and sit and listen to a
podcast or something and I knew the
owner my brother worked there um the
owner would pay me like 10 bucks an hour
to fix his computer
and about eight years ago he comes to me
and he's like hey I'm going to sell the
business I want to make sure it goes
into good hands will you buy it and I
don't know anything about the bakery or
anything but I kind of want to protect
this like cool neighborhood institution
and so and you want to be like a big
shot you want to be like oh yeah come
hang out of my place you know like would
you like some of my bread yeah totally
there's like there's always like a pride
of ownership right like if I tell
someone let's say like locally I'm like
hey I own this huge social network for
graphic designers dribbble they're like
you know eyes glaze over they don't care
but if I say oh I own otavio like the
local bakery that everybody goes to with
their kids they're like whoa that's so
cool so there's a lot of Pride ownership
but there's like 30 or 40 employees um
you know we have to have meure like a
baker wakes up at 2 in the morning to
bake the croissants a million different
things have to go right to serve a
customer and have them have a good
experience right and this business is
like you know it goes from making money
one month to losing money for six months
um you know T huge swings if like one
person quits it messes up everything
super complicated to operate um and if
we're lucky at the end of all of that
we'll maybe make 150 Grand a year now on
the flips side we bought a business
about almost 10 years ago called
weworkremotely.com and it's very simple
it's a job board people pay money to
post like a Blue Link kind of like uh
Craigslist so you're hiring remote you
post on we work remotely uh it would be
like you know I'm hiring a developer for
you know automatic or whatever so we
were when we bought that business they
were charging
$1.99 and it was run by the guys from
base camp and they just didn't do any
marketing or promotion didn't do any SEO
so we buy the business uh we pay three
or four times earnings or something
which was you know a fair price given
what it was doing um we immediately take
the price from $1.99 to 99 because
that's what all the other job boards
were charging and we hire an SEO
consultant we started doing SEO we
started doing email marketing that
business went from doing about 400k of
profit to I think a couple years ago it
did 4 million of IA or something in that
range so these in that business that had
two employees and one or two part-time
contractors right and literally like the
entire team could go pens down for 6
months and it would still keep printing
cash and so you look at it and it's like
business on har hard mode versus
business on easy mode but the
inexperienced entrepreneur would look at
the bakery and go ooh sexy right and
it's like online there's bakeries too
right e-commerce businesses are bakeries
in my opinion how much of uh what was uh
so for those who don't know Andrew he
took his kind of his holding company
took public I think today it's trading
many hundreds of millions of dollars
five or $600 million doar what were your
earnings that you reported for last
quarter or what's like the public uh
record for your annual earnings I think
it was between 30 and 40 that's like the
public number I think but what's crazy
is that we work remotely would have
accounted for something like 10 or 15%
of of you know this company worth
hundreds of millions of dollars of your
guys' earnings that's pretty wild well I
think a lot of people forget that small
things can get big right we grew that we
took that business uh from 400k we
basically 10x it and we we bought that
business I think for about 1.5 million
right so it's pretty it's pretty wild
how powerful this stuff can be when you
see a business where they're just not
they're myopic on something they're not
doing the best practices and often it's
because they have other priorities I
mean the base camp guys had aund million
do AR SAS business the last thing
they're going to be thinking about is
this little pimple on their ass this you
know remote job board uh so buying
buying from someone like that is a great
opportunity I was talking to one of your
company uh CEOs last night and um they
mentioned this profit first book which I
think is interesting uh Sam do you know
about this everyone is talking about
that Andrew told me about it months ago
and since then I've seen like eight or
nine friends bring it up I don't know
what it's about though I'll give you my
take and then Andrew you you fill in the
gaps because I haven't read the book but
I was like can you just explain it to me
in 5 seconds and then they explained it
to me in 5 seconds and I was like oh got
it and that makes a ton of sense so
here's the the the ultra I haven't read
the book version of of the book which
is in a normal business you get Revenue
Topline and then you start you know you
get your gross profit so like a revenue
minus what it took to sell it to sell
those goods and then you have like all
these other expenses and then what
what's left is like the profit at the
end so profits at the end normally and
then you sort of take a distribution out
of it that's probably how you ran the
hustle yeah or you take no distributions
because you're just paranoid um and
that's how I run my e-commerce business
and I think what the profit first
mentality is you take the gross profit
and you put that in your bank account
and then as you have bills to pay you
literally put it in your bank account or
figuratively you literally move it you
move it into a profit bank that you
don't you don't see you sweep it out of
the company got it you sweep it out of
the company then the company gets a bill
from some vendor or some software and
then you have to go back and you have to
now take money out of that pocket and
pay it and there's something
psychological about when you just accept
the waterfall of expenses and you're
like I guess I get what's left you sort
of leave the fat in the company versus
if I paid you out everything and then I
said hey Sam um it's GNA be eight grand
to use this software or whatever like
eight grand for this I don't want to I
have to take eight grand out of my
pocket and pay for this you start to
question a bunch of these expenses and
it sort of forces you to get lean even
though nothing changed except for the
order of operations but does that ruin
growth does that like does that ruin
when you see an opportunity and you want
to pounce on it like well no because you
would just you would just you'd take
that money and you'd invest it back into
the company and first Andrew did I did I
bastardize it or was that was that
accurate description I think you nailed
it I mean um the way to think about it
is like if you want to lose weight you
know there's that all these um
psychological experiments where they
give people food on different sizes of
plates and the bigger the plate the more
they eat because psychologically you
know they got to get through all that
food so the idea here is smaller plate
so yeah you if you make a hundred bucks
you you immediately take away 30 and
people are just forced to eat off a
smaller plate and so they eat less and
they're more thoughtful about expenses
but how do you do the math to figure out
how much cash to leave in the bank well
I think you would always say that um
let's say that your business
historically has run with a 30% net
profit margin you would always scrape
out 30% and over time if there's excess
cash they're more profitable you keep
increasing that threshold right because
you want to be running as as um as
optimal as possible one of the weirdest
things I've noticed in business is that
everybody all CEOs seem to go you know
what 25% profit that's good let's Le you
know that that's what we should manage
to yeah that's how I feel I do that what
I've seen is that some of our businesses
historically not at all times can
operate with 80 or 90% net profit
margins and if we got a dreamer in there
right if we got a CEO like me from 20
years ago or Sean from 20 years ago we'd
be going going oh let's innovate let's
do all these new things and they'd burn
through all that cash so I think it's a
way of creating discipline now we
haven't actually implemented this I've
gone to all the CEOs and asked them to
read it and some of them have got
excited and implemented it but um I
think it's a really interesting
framework especially for smaller
companies our buddy uh suly does this so
I was like how much working because like
our Ecom bank balance is getting bigger
I was like how much should I leave in
there versus uh you know distribute out
um and he was like I just distributed it
all out and I was like all of it like
what about like three months of working
capital and he's like okay you can leave
a month or two but he's like people act
like you can't just put money back in
the bank account like you can always put
money back in the Banky there's no
penalty for this and he's like I think
you have way better discipline when
there's not this huge bank balance
sitting there and uh you know and I was
like oh okay I guess you're right there
is no like penalty or you know for just
sending the money back into the bank
account when it's needed but you will
question is this really needed and why
is this needed and what happened last
month that is leading us to in Capital
back in I've I've like yelled at Sam
over text a few times about this many
super conservative I'm really
conservative I've changed though so
starting January 1 uh we're making the
change um where I'm taking out a lot of
the money and we're actually just
putting it into like T bills into a
different account to figure out what do
we want to do with the money um maybe
we'll pay ourselves a little bit I
haven't paid myself anything from
Hampton at the moment but maybe we'll
pay ourselves money as well but yeah I'm
I'm you've convinced me that that's the
right way and I'm I have to read this
book what I'm still trying to figure out
is how much Capital keep in the business
I don't know if I want to like do so
let's say your business is is spending
$500,000 a month in expenses do you just
leave in like one month's expense what's
the equation for Chris Chris and I we
used to leave two weeks expenses in the
business no way really if it meant that
if they don't collect their AR their
accounts receivable they go off a cliff
now what they don't know is they're not
going to go off a cliff because tiny the
bank we'll just inject more Capital
we're sitting on cash and so we move it
in but it creates this sense of urgency
to do Collections and run the business
very efficiently so that math is
basically if you're doing uh uh 12.5
million in Revenue you have 10 million
in profit you're only leaving something
like 500 Grand in the bank yeah yeah so
like basically payroll payroll plus
expenses for two to four weeks Max
that's wild that's stressful but I I
agree that's the right way to do it not
well it's not though because I mean most
of the time especially in a recurring
Revenue business right like we'll do
this with especially with SAS businesses
because it's very predictable we will
say Okay um you know you always do 300K
Mr so you know we're going to give you
you know two weeks of cash because it's
very predictable now once in a while
maybe once a year they'll say hey can
you inject 100K to help us make payroll
or something like that or for R&D but to
go back to Sean's point they have to
validate the R&D whereas if the money is
there they'll just take it and do the
R&D are you going to do this Sean yeah
I'm going to change it because I am like
very guilty of this like when I heard
this it was like oh I've heard a truth I
can't unhear and this is for bootstrap
companies specifically um because you
know otherwise I I don't want to belabor
the point but yeah like the it's so easy
to just accept all your expenses as
expenses that are necessary or required
it's easy to oh what's the difference
between this much net profit per month
or this much I'm not taking it out
anyway so I don't really feel the
difference whereas if my paycheck is
less I'm like where's the rest of it and
then I have to go answer that question
and so I think this is such a I look for
forcing functions and I think this is an
amazing forcing function that like
initially I was ready to poo poo this
book I was like what is this stupid idea
and then as soon as I heard it flipped
flip my opinion there's there's a really
good quote on that I was talking there
friend about this who runs a SAS company
I won't say who but he has 65% net
margins and he's been running this SAS
business for 20 plus years um growing
you know 20 30% bootstrapped every year
just amazing amazing business and great
entrepreneur and I was telling him about
how we had not done this in certain
businesses and how the CEOs had
misallocated some of that cash and he
looks at me and he just goes if you ask
the dinner guests what's for dinner they
will always say steak and I was like oh
my God that's so true right it's like
why wouldn't they you know it's not
their money they you know yes don't get
me wrong like a CEO is incentivized for
a bonus but for a CEO's bonus they can
spend $300,000 of your money and that
might only be worth 10 or $20,000 bonus
for them they don't care as much um you
know every dollar counts when it's you
and you're the owner operator I did the
same thing when I sold my house I I was
like okay um I forgot we were selling it
for like let's say it was 2.1 and I was
like I think we could get 2.2 and the
agent was like I don't know maybe it's
2.1 and I was like well I I get it you
want to make the sale and move on but I
was like you know and I thought oh we're
both aligned if if it's 2.2 he gets more
and I get more and I realized well this
guy gets 3% he gets an extra three grand
I get an extra 97 Grand if it's 2.1 I
was like this guy doesn't give a [__]
about that three grand um you know he's
getting uh whatever you know 3% of the 2
million anyways this three grand is like
not worth the time and Hassle and risk
of pushing a negotiation and so I
incentivized him I was like how about
this let's cut a new deal and he's ready
for me to like cut him down and I go no
for every dollar you get me above 2.1
you're going to keep 15% of it and sure
enough and I made a I also had a penalty
I said and if you don't sell it for at
least 2.1 you got to buy my wife this
bag and I was like cuz I was like I
don't want to take money out of this
guy's pocket but I also want him to feel
the pain so I made it a goofy gift I was
like are like these like expensive
slippers that like clearly are a waste
of [__] money and he was like and
then literally we got down to it we got
an offer it was around
2.12 let's say and uh I was honestly
ready to take it at that point but he
was like he was like it's about 2.1 I
don't know like you know let's see if we
can push back he's like I really don't
want to buy that bag uh so he's like I'm
GNA for sure get it over this he's like
let me see how far I can get it and um
he's like let me go push one more time
and he pushed one more time we got a
better deal and it was just such a
simple like lesson around uh really
understanding the incentives and not
just like the like on paper incentives
but like is this enough to move the
needle for this person to behave
differently or not I I think it's so
crazy the more that I go through working
with other people in business I realize
that everything comes down to incentives
and if you just think about the
incentive you'll see the you know the
exact behavior that they're going to
have I did this the same thing when I
was selling a house Chris had an
interesting point he was making um stink
bids on houses so if you look at like a
million dollar house he would go and
he'd bid 650 or 700 and he'd do that 10
or 20 times and the realtor was pushing
back over and over and over again oh you
know they'll never accept that there's
no point because think about it the
realtor got to go they got to spend 30
to 40 minutes writing out the offer send
it and for them they're going there's 5%
chance totally worth it for Chris but
not for the realtor and they're only
going to get one commission and so Chris
started saying hey look for every offer
you send I'm going to pay you ,000
immediately the guy's totally down to do
the stink bids but before that he's
going oh you're going to get a bad
reputation in the market you're going to
offend everyone don't do it it's so
funny I don't know if this is public so
Sean will have to verify because he's
closer to this person but we've got
buddies that if you're like I've been
with them in La when we were there uh
doing like an event or when they're
visiting New York you'll be like hey
what are you doing today like oh I'm
going to go see these three apartments
or these three houses that I that I'm
looking at and I was like you're looking
a move he's like no I just tour these
constantly and I put lowball offers on
all of them and every once in a while
someone will will take the bait and I
get a screaming deal is that right Sean
is that what they do yeah that's right
that's right and they just like are
doing these doing this constantly and
they do the exact same thing has any of
those stink bids ever worked yeah I mean
uh dude it's just like some people like
bargain shopping at Ross try to find
that Hidden Gem that's in the basket
that they know is worth more some people
like to go to garage sales and then if
you're just a little bit richer you do
the same thing on the level of houses
essentially you're like oh good if I can
lob all these houses you know touring
hous is also pretty fun and uh yeah
they've they' picked up a couple of
assets that we have a mutual friend all
of us and he buys companies and he was
telling me what his funnel was he
basically said I think they own 18
companies he said that they looked at
1,000 companies and I think they met
with hundreds many many hundreds and
then he said they they did Lois for like
200 of them and only 15 or 18 or
something like that closed and I didn't
realize Andrew how much all right when I
think of like a holding company or
whatever you're doing I think of it this
way mostly because you give off this
Vibe which I think you mean to do it on
purpose but I don't think it's the
reality which is like oh I just sit back
and everyone does the work and maybe
they're doing a lot of the work running
the companies but what I've learned
about buying companies and I think
Sean's learning this too cuz I know he's
meeting with a lot of people it is a
sales job and you are hitting the phones
and you are creating a funnel and that
funnel still has like a 3% conversion
rate so in order to buy three companies
you got to talk to 100 people I didn't
realize how sales oriented this whole
thing was that you guys are doing well
for us I wouldn't say it is I would say
in the early days it was for sure but um
we've realized that like cold Outreach
is not the way to go like we would much
rather go and have a public presence and
a reputation and have people actually
seek us out and say Hey I want to sell
you my company I've I've I want to
connect with you I don't want to be some
random private Equity Firm that's like
hey you know let me tell you about us
and do the dog and pony show and stuff I
want you're still doing marketing so
instead of doing instead of doing sales
you're doing marketing the funnel still
exists yeah totally and and I did not
realize that have you noticed that Sean
while you're trying to buy stuff yeah I
mean we just started this process let's
say a year ago very much inspired by you
Andrew of like uh hey this is a
wonderful way to basically like own
businesses without having to create them
from scratch gives a good win to the
person who's selling them and we will
buy minority which I I don't know if you
guys always do but like we will also buy
minority of them minority stake in them
um but the thing that's yeah Sam you're
absolutely right it's obviously like you
have to sort through so many just to
find something worth buying and then
even when you find something worth
buying doesn't mean the deal's going to
happen even when you think a deal is
going to happen it doesn't mean a deal
closes and so you end up with this like
tiny tiny funnel and you have to be okay
with hey we might do one deal this year
or no deals this year it's so different
than like entrepreneurship where it's
all about action it's all about features
it's all about you know more customers
more more more more more and actually
less less less is almost you know the
name of the game when it comes to being
very selective picking the right asset
the hard part I think is a lot of people
overinvestment
and so tell me these three things so
it'll be like okay um who runs the
business right is that you do you want
to stay or go and um and then what are
your earnings and then after that once I
have that info I say okay we would
probably pay about X right and if they
say ye you know let's talk then I know I
should spend the time and talk but I
think a lot of people will actually have
three or four conversations and like
slow roll and I'm like I'm like via
email I want to send the first offer I
want want them to say yes that's
interesting and then I'll spend time on
it and what I used to do is I would
spend all this time getting to know
people and unboxing the business only to
realize that their expectations were
insane and we would waste a ton of time
and just like with um bidding on real
estate or anything else we throw out
Lois constantly like I have no qualms
about that they're not binding documents
uh you know we'll send someone an offer
and there's something about if I if I
write an email and I say hey I'll offer
you $2 million for your business I don't
think people take as seriously as when
there's like a formal document laying it
all out hey on April 30th you will get
$2 million in this exact structure uh
this is what we commit to people take it
seriously so we we send them out all the
time so I've never told this story I
don't think publicly but Sean about four
or six years ago the hustle was two or
three years old I was down in the dumps
I was feeling really bad about myself I
was feeling bad about the business and I
told this person that I was not feeling
great and they said said you know have
you thought about selling it I would
really be interested in buying it and
this guy um I was like H maybe he goes
look let's just hang out and meet come
up to uh where I am and and fly up here
and I was like okay maybe and he goes
yeah yeah I'm going to send the jet I'm
GNA I'm going to send you a jet and I
was like what do you mean a jet like I
get like I'm GNA fly private like yeah
I'm sending the jet so I take all these
this is right when Tik Tok came out I
one of the first Tik toks was me on this
jet it was like I was like I can't
believe this I go to the private
Executive Airport my first time ever
doing that I get on the plane I'm in my
own jet I have got the Wall Street
Journal sitting there and they offer me
like champagne and all this stuff I'm
like this is the craziest thing I can't
believe this I was in heaven I meet with
the guy and I'm wooed I'm so floored by
this and I'm like days away from being
like yeah I'm willing to do something
then thankfully I snap out of the the
the mood and I'm like it's okay I can
keep going but that my friends is how I
met Andrew Wilkinson in real life he was
the one who sent me the jet he sent me a
jet and he totally wanted and die me I
was such a redneck he goes I lived in
San Francisco he goes oh I'm in
Vancouver I was like I got to go to New
York though and I don't want to have to
like I guess I'll fly to New York and
then you could send the Jet and we'll
just bolt right up and I was thinking
Vancouver was Toronto I didn't I thought
Vancouver was next to New York I didn't
even know where it was he goes dude
Vancouver is right by San Francisco it's
only to be two or three hours but uh he
flew me up there and I don't know if you
owned a bakery at the time you took me
to a bakery and you guys totally tried
to like whine and dine me that's how I
met Andrew I was like Head Over Heels
just cuz he sent this jet it worked that
you know that's actually the only time
I've ever done that I think it full of
[__] it's no I'm Ser 100% I'm I'm I've
picked up friends and we've done that
kind of stuff before like if we're
having an event we've flown people in
but um I've only ever done that for you
that's the one time and I think it was
CU you said you're afraid of flying or
there's it totally worked it totally
work of fly
commercial if only there was some other
option the time out I was thinking about
uh I was thinking a lot about newspapers
and I was like oh Sam you've built like
the modern version of the newspaper
you've got something really incredible I
think your deal with HubSpot though is
better than what we would have
paid we got to the numbers and we would
have been cheaper than HubSpot well and
it was like I think a two years
difference I I I remember we I went to I
even I was supposed to get married on a
Friday or Saturday and you wanted to
meet me on a Tuesday and I was like
Sarah you think I could swing this this
guy's Gonna Fly me private I got to do
this you know I'll be I I'll miss maybe
one of the events I have to do this and
it was like uh so that was in 2020 and
so we ended up selling a little bit
later so it worked out for everyone but
that's how I met you I will say one of
the things I've learned from you Andrew
is uh you are a master networker and
normally networking is like this it's
like this compliment you don't want to
get um you know but but you're actually
great at it and obviously networking is
valuable people would love to have a
great Network and meet cool people and
have excuses to do things together and
I've seen seen you kind of throw your
weight around in that area and this
might be like asking Michael Jordan like
you know how do you shoot a jump shot or
how do you jump so high you know like
it's like they can't really explain it's
not conscious or that they don't really
know how to explain it but I've seen you
do this with like you want to meet
somebody who's really interesting and
you'll find a good excuse to get
connected with them or even how we met
like you know you listen to the podcast
and then you were like hey I'd love to
you know meet you let's do a call and
you really kind of took the time to do
something that you didn't otherwise have
to do um and that's how we met we had a
great conversation then that led to kind
of like us hanging out a little bit more
and so I've seen you do this with like
pretty influential people I've seen you
bring people up to Canada where you're
at like you know the sort of home court
advantage type of thing like do you have
if I was to say like you know how do you
do it um and and by the way I the when I
was having dinner with the CEO of one of
your companies the other day they said
the same thing they go nobody's better
than Andrew when it comes to to building
an awesome Network who did you meet by
the way uh Zach he lives like oh yeah a
minute away from so so what's your
what's your first date routine for
meeting all these people building a
network well it totally depends I mean I
amum
so here's an example so in 2016 I was
reading um a profile on Dan Gilbert Sean
or Sam I think you know or both you guys
know who he is he's the quick and Loans
rocket mortgage guy and it was really
cool it was all about how he'd taken his
entire fortune and basically was trying
to rebuild the city of Detroit uh and I
I thought that was really cool I thought
you know you see all these guys who get
super rich and then they put their money
into like mutual funds right I think
that's incredibly boring this guy's
trying to rebuild a city he's buying
skyscrapers he's starting all these
businesses so I just emailed him I cold
emailed him at like 1 in the morning and
I said hey you know here's three bullets
about me and I thought about what is he
interested in and so I mentioned that I
own that Bakery I mentioned I'm
passionate about my city I mentioned I
bootstrapped my business you know tried
to find a few points of similarity and
said I would love to meet you um anytime
anywhere you know if you're going to be
in a random City in Del you know
somewhere in Delaware I will fly to you
just tell me when we could meet and I
got an email response back like 20
minutes later saying sure and we ended
up meeting up in Detroit and he was
amazing we spent an afternoon together
gave me a tour of the city um got to
know a whole bunch of people on his team
and it was awesome so I will shoot shots
like that when see someone that I'm
interested in but there's certain people
that are like inaccessible like I wanted
to meet Bill Amman i' you know been
reading about him for years been falling
you know watching every YouTube video
listening to every interview and first I
was like okay he's an investor in
Chipotle um maybe we could redesign I
own all these agencies maybe we could
redesign the Chipotle website maybe we
could do an app and so I email him and I
say hey I'm a shareholder in your public
company um you know I've got this
amazing design agency I'd love to help
in any way I can and he intros me to
like one of the board members so I was
like damn it you know like I just got
handed off but but he he replied to the
email though that was good I mean
replied to the email you just yeah
basically just forwarded somebody but I
was like okay I know his email like
there something will happen here and I
just have to wait for it and then I saw
this charity lunch go up and uh
basically every year he auctions off a
lunch and this year this was in like
he was having a terrible down year he
got divorced he had like the Herbal Life
stuff he invested in Valiant
pharmaceutical everyone was kind of like
[__] on him he was being very quiet
and so there weren't as many bids as
usual to do this and so I ended up
bidding
$57,000 to go have lunch with him and my
bet was I had no I had no expectation
there'd be any business to do because
he's a hedge fund manager I'm a tech
investor but um but I knew he'd be like
an interesting person to meet and so I
went and we ended up connecting and then
at the end of the lunch he kind of
pulled me aside and he's like hey I like
you if you ever want to do a deal
together let me know and so years later
we ended up buying a business and he
invested with us just like sub you a
piece of paper that says do you like me
back yes or no like the bo my foot twice
yeah well see that's what I'm talking
about that's amazing you do the same
thing I with Charlie Munger and Buffett
right you you did the charity lunch you
bought you bought the charity lunch is
that right no no so that was a friend
just a that was totally random that was
a my friend Andrew Marx who um he he
knew Charlie personally and he said hey
I'm putting together a dinner and then
through that you know I started sending
Charlie letters I knew that Charlie is
not someone you communicate verbally
with he likes he likes to talk a lot and
so and uh you can't communicate with him
that way you got to write him letters so
Chris and I started writing him letters
but um but yeah I mean I don't know I
like people I'm very extroverted what
are you saying in these letters I would
just say like hey here before the dinner
I said hey here's who we are this is the
business this is what we do and he you
know throughout the dinner knew who we
were as a result and then we started
asking for his opinions and talking
about different ways we could help him
with stuff um I I think like the
fundamental principle is be of value to
other people and then also um say yes to
interesting people if someone can if
someone appears to be interesting I will
have lunch with them did he reply to the
letters he would just call us we would
we then call him and he would verbally
he's he like verbally um he'll
communicate to you verbally but you have
to write to him if you want to remember
him to remember
anything that's amazing uh sounds like a
book like uh like my pimpel Charlie you
know you gotta like save all the letters
in the back and forth totally I think uh
it's great to see you know like I would
say there's like two takeaways for me
one is like I feel like you check your
ego really well like uh you are humble
about wanting to meet these people and
you're about wanting to meet these
people and you're not like you're not
Bey you're not like above just shooting
a shot and saying hey you know I think
you're great here's what we do that
might be relevant for you and helpful
for you uh you know would love to
connect I think the other thing is um
you're willing to spend money you're
willing to hop on the flight you're
willing to buy the charity thing you're
willing to to to be a part of their
their program that they're launching
because you know they care about that
right now and uh I think people are
pretty everybody sort of understands
that like having a valuable network is
valuable but very few people are willing
to invest because it's not a clear like
dollars in dollars out thing and that's
one thing I've picked up from you you
got to be really careful about it though
because so about 12 13 years ago um I
remember I when I was first starting my
company I would watch TED talks back
when they were like really early and I
would always go oh my God I want to be
in this room like who are these people
it's like Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates and
you know all these amazing people and so
um probably like 13 14 years ago I
started going to Ted Global and I
started at the kind of baby event the
junior one uh the only one I could get
into and then I slowly worked my way
into going to the main event because I
met Chris Anderson who ran Ted and I
pitched him on doing a TED app and so I
designed the TED app I used that to get
into the main one and then I ended up
meeting all these interesting people and
so that was an example where I belonged
but I was like the baby I was like the
kid who's like you know people would
ruffle my hair oh isn't that cute this
23-year-old with a you know cracking
voice runs a company um but I kind of
belong so I I think that's a great
strategy sometimes but this year I went
to the Oscars and I went to the Vanity
Fair Afterparty and that was an example
of something where I'm like I should not
be here and you do not want that
experience right that's not tell that
story tell that story so yeah so it's
really random so I was at a conference
uh about a year ago and I sat across
from this guy and I asked him about his
startup and usually when you're at these
conferences they're like oh I own a B2B
software company for doing HR or
something and this guy said something
that really caught my attention he goes
I run a startup that helps people
convert money into an interesting life
and I was like whoa okay what is this
and so he has this company called myria
m y RI and the idea is basically they
Deep dive with you on um you know what
do you care about what are you excited
about what do you want your life to look
like so they kind of like paint out a
blueprint like in two years you know do
you want to be um what kind of people do
you want to be hanging out with uh what
do you aspire to get involved with you
know what are your passions what do you
want to do with your money and then they
help you figure that out and so I did it
I signed up and they interviewed me and
I said I love movies and they said well
do you want to go to the Oscars and I
was like I've never contemplated that
but I was like you know what that sounds
like a fun experience I think spending
money on funny experiences like that is
worth it and so we go me and my
girlfriend go down they set up like a
personal stylist we buy like
ridiculously expensive clothes and
tuxedos and you know I get like a $500
haircut like just silly silly stuff and
you know it's it's kind of cool we're in
um the actual Oscar event and we keep
seeing famous people and it's great
people watching and stuff um but after
that we go to the Vanity Fair afterparty
and I don't know if you guys know but
Vanity Fair Afterparty is this like
super exclusive event where literally
everybody is famous if there's five
people there four of them are b or a
list celebrities and the one that you
don't recognize is probably like a super
famous director or producer or something
so I'm standing at the bar and like to
my right is John Ham chatting it up with
Jeff Bezos uh you know I see this guy
checking out my girlfriend and I realize
it's Andrew Garfield like very weird I
can hear like Seth Rogan laughing behind
me Rihanna struts in like it's just
pinch me like the weirdest thing in the
world and then there's me and my
girlfriend and over and over again every
person that walks by us looks us up and
down looks a bit excited looks us up and
down realizes we're not famous and then
immediately turns on their heel and
we're just like you know this is kind of
weird we don't belong here and I start
making conversation with people I'm you
know I'm very I start trying to chitchat
with people and as soon as I said oh I'm
not in the film industry I'm in tech
people would just immediately glaze over
and start looking over my shoulder like
did not care could not care less right
and you know it was I kind of gave up at
a certain point I just kind of was like
all right let's just people watch or
whatever but I realized that I'm really
used to being in rooms where like
obviously I'm not famous but I have like
respect like you know if I even if I'm
at a dental conference I can probably
chat with someone and be like oh you're
the like you know you're the business
guy at the dent at the dentist you know
clinic or whatever we can talk business
but I realized I had no shared language
for these people um and it's just not
fun like you want to be in a room where
you actually have value and so imagine
like I was a web designer and I'm like I
want to be an investor I want to meet
Bill Amman if I have no value to him or
I'm not interesting to him I should not
meet him you have to wait until you're
interesting and ironically since I went
to the Oscars we ended up buying
letterboxed which is a social network
it's like the largest social network for
film
Buffs now if I go back to that same
party I'm sure people would be like oh
cool right but it's interesting you you
had a great phrase you said you said I
realize that you want to earn the room
that you're in and uh I thought that was
like because I didn't know at first like
what would the what's the takeaway of
the story is it just like you know I
don't know sometimes you go to these
parties you feel uncomfortable but
you're you're actually right about that
you do want to you don't want to buy
your way into a room you want to earn
your way into a room and uh I do think
that that's a that's a great takeaway
totally listen to the uh the copy on the
miria so it's mia. us it says Parker
Wayne Kent Stark why should they have
all the fun Mia memberships gives you
and your team special powers to make
your life more enjoyable and the world a
better place and they say say open
sesame to the world's top private clubs
and make sold out disappear from your
vocabulary
well done this is a very well done site
is this is this company going to be
something legit and big I they went
through white combinator it couple
episodes ago too I think um I think it's
a really really cool idea and I think
the idea like do you ever go to a city
and you're like [__] you know we didn't
plan like I remember me and my
girlfriend went to Tokyo and we kind of
went last minute and we ended up eating
bad food we didn't really like see the
best of the city we just hadn't planned
it and so it just so wasted and it's one
of those instances where I wish I had
something like this it's like the key to
the city where you're like hey I'm in
Tokyo I want to go to all the coolest
stuff you know all my tastes curate
something for me or like Chris wanted to
go to F1 and he doesn't know anyone at
F1 he doesn't know how it works he
wanted to go last minute these guys got
him like I think he met Lewis Hamilton
he went in the pit you know stuff like
that is like pretty cool um but I yeah
it would be interesting to see because
they raised Venture we actually invested
in their um their angel round
immediately because I was like this is
such a funny idea but um I don't know if
it'll be Venture scale we'll see they
have a competitor that I uh looked at
and I was poking on the website they say
you have to spend $80,000 a month in
order to make it be worth it so on
average a million dollars a year uh to
make these yeah 25 I think it's 25 Grand
and then they take a cut of everything
you do so if you spend $100,000 I think
they would take a 15% fee or something
on that there's another service I just
got invited to and my friend so he tells
me about it and it's basically um last
minute super highend reservations at any
restaurant you want to eat at in like
New York London and Miami and I'm like
oh cool you should invite me and he's
like no you don't get it if you don't
use this invite I lose access and the
guy who invited me loses access which I
think is like genius so it's like forget
what it's called but basically you in if
I invite Shawn um you have use it within
30 days otherwise I lose my access and S
if Sam invited me he loses it too
there's some uh little Trend I've
noticed which is people as they get more
successful or notable or whatever the
number of times they hear no in their
life goes way down and I've actually
noticed that like there's a whole
business in just the business of no for
people that no longer hear no and what
this means is twofold one is they still
run into some things that they don't
know how to they they can't like they
their powers are useless here it's like
it's sold out what do you want me to do
and so these guys with muria have
created a business around we eliminate
the last few NOS of your life and I've
noticed other people like this kind of
uh hey if you don't use this I get
kicked out it's like I don't get kicked
out of anything nowadays right like I'm
paying the fees what why would they kick
me out but there's a whole business
around give people something to lose who
never hear know anymore they never get
rejected anymore and it's like give them
some rejection give them some way that
they have some some risk uh because it
makes them like feel like something
matters when everything is in Easy Mode
for them at that so I um I I've been on
the wait list to go to Peter do you guys
know who Peter AA is super famous doctor
um I I am I've been on the weit list
there for like three years his private
practice you mean private private
practice which is like you know I think
he only has 50 patients it's like
getting it's like getting hubman or
someone to be your doctor yeah it's
super expensive and so I pay I pay like
this absurd amount of money up front and
they do this thing where they
psychologically test you before they
allow you to become a patient and so I
go through this test and Peter calls me
and he goes Andrew um there was
something concerning in your uh your
personality test I'm worried that you
won't have good follow through will you
do what I say will you execute on the
plan and I'm like Peter no like you got
it all wrong like I I pay attention to
my diet like I track everything I wear a
glucose monitor like you don't have to
worry about me and he goes okay cool and
so you know I've been working with them
and last month I pull him aside and I'm
like Peter look be honest with me did I
actually have like something in my
psychological test and he goes you you
did I was like is that even a real test
and he's like yeah that is right so I
actually did flag something but I was
thinking what a great strategy because
I'm like the dream patient now I'm like
terrified of getting booted out because
of this thing he said and I think doing
something like that you're right pushing
someone away
creates this desire to be a good
customer has it been worth it his his
him being your doctor well I think I
think it's so it's a lot of money
obviously it's hundreds of thousands of
dollars um but if think about it this
way if you're gaining five years of life
or 10 years of life what is that worth
and there's been quite a few things I
have I have an amazing doctor a primary
doctor that I go to um who I love and
he's amazing but AA they have like a
neurology a cardiologist um exercise
physiologist who works with you so it's
this team of people and they caught um a
bunch of issues with cholesterol and
other stuff that I may not have caught
otherwise so I I mean I think it's worth
it but for a normal person is that a
good use of money no I would say that's
a crazy use of money you went to your
primary doctor you're like Doc I love
you it's been a great 20 years yeah we
have to talk I met Angelina Jolie now
and uh we have a thing going
too we're now in an open doctor
relationship it's really yeah it's one
of those things I used to think you
could only have one lawyer like I had
one one lawyer and then I'd feel like I
was cheating on my lawyer if I used
other lawyers then I realized like no
you have lawyers for different things or
whatever but yeah I have uh now I've got
a polyamorous uh doctor relationship
let's do uh you have this this idea of
be the Barnacle on the whale what does
that mean yeah so um if you think about
one of the biggest costs in most
businesses it's marketing so um you know
if you think about it it's like 15 to
30% of most businesses is just getting
people to know you exist and getting
sales so if you can own a business that
doesn't have to Market itself then
you're golden you can run a super super
profitable business so let's say that
with marketing you run it 15% cut
marketing you could run it 45 50 60% so
for example um let's say that you're a
fitness influencer so like think about
like Derek from more plates more dates
so he sells um uh supplements and energy
drinks and he's got this shampoo for
hair loss he's got a great business
because he is free marketing he just
talks about the product on his podcast
his YouTube uh his Instagram and he gets
free sales right so it would be an as an
e-commerce business if he was paying to
acquire those customers it'd be a crappy
business but he's got free marketing
right now the problem is most of us
don't have access to that most of us are
not influencers but anyone can do that
in a different way by being a barnacle
on a whale so here's the story of how we
I kind of stumbled into this um so I was
at a conference about 12 years ago um at
the time I met um Harley and Toby from
Shopify Shopify was this tiny little
startup they were bootstrapped they were
like 15 people and they said hey we
really like your design work um would
you design some themes for us but
there's a catch this won't be client
work we're not going to pay you uh we
want you to list them in our Marketplace
so the idea is like when people sign up
for Shopify they wanted people to be
able to select a theme and pay like $49
to $250 to do that I started making
$5,000 a month $110,000 a month as these
themes sold and I was like hey this is
really cool like I'm not having to
promote it I don't have to think about
marketing or SEO or anything you know
people they they send all the traffic to
their Marketplace and so we started
building more and more themes and we
ended up spinning out that business but
what what I didn't realize was that in
the theme Marketplace there was only so
many squares and it took time to build
the themes and it took time for them to
get approved and so I started owning
more and more squares so let's say that
in the early days if you were to choose
a theme there's a 50% chance that it was
one of ours so we had like saturation
early in this Marketplace that was very
small when we joined it but then as
Shopify grew I mean you guys know what
happened they go public they start
pouring hundreds of millions of dollars
into marketing I get free marketing I
get to be the little Barnacle on the
whale and keep growing and it got to the
point where that business was big enough
um that we ended up taking that public
at a $260 million valuation a couple
years ago so um it's an incredible
strategy now I think Shopify is hard
because you're late you know the the
marketplace already exists it takes a
lot of time to get approved you know
that might not be the place to go where
you might want to look is um like
Discord or adapar or any kind of
software ecosystem that's not super
saturated if you can go be a barnacle on
a whale you can make a ton of money I
totally agree I have a a a business
that's cooking up that's like this I
I'll I'll tell you later uh offline
because I can't can't announce it yet
but totally agree with this strategy I
think it's amazing you invested so you
said it went public at 260 million
how much did you invest to get there
sounds like it was kind of some free
labor to get the themes going but like
how much Capital did it take for you to
get going because you were early $20,000
maybe so that's incredible and didn't
you sell you sold that business for 15
million or did you sell it for 10 and
bought it back for 15 there's like a
story where you sold it and then bought
it back right yeah so basically started
it for 20K sold it for about 7 million
um to and then I ended up buying it back
from the guys who bought it for2 million
and then about a year later we took a
public for 260 million so talk about
that like did you sell it like did you
regret selling it or what why sell it in
the first place was that a mistake and
then psychologically how'd you get
yourself to buy it back for so three
times as much yeah like Sam I was like
in this kind of like existential crisis
I was super burnt out I've been running
so I I had that business I had metalab I
had two SAS companies I had an
e-commerce business I was running all of
them kind of of running around like a
chicken with my head cut off and finally
I hit a wall and I was feeling really
depressed talked to a friend he said hey
why don't you sell one and um were you
were you liquid at that point like were
you financially secure no no I I was
Liquid in that we had a lot of cash flow
but the problem was I'd be um borrowing
from Peter to pay paal right so I have
at any given time I'd have a highly
profitable business and then I have a
startup and the startup would burn all
the profits so I didn't have a nice
house like you know I I was okay but I
always felt like I was going to go broke
and so getting that cash influx was
amazing so I sell the business um
suddenly I'm sitting on millions of
dollars and feeling very secure and the
first thing I do is I go okay now that
I've got all this money I got to learn
how to invest it and so I pick up a book
about Warren Buffett and I start reading
about this idea of competitive advantage
in Moes and what a good business looks
like and as I'm reading I'm going oh my
God I just sold the business that has
all these qu qu what the hell was I
thinking uh and I was still on the board
so the nice thing was I helped them
choose the CEO this amazing guy named
Ben Mo and I just kept watching and
eventually the guys who we sold it to
they were fatigued they wanted to they
had they had um they had kind of
transitioned to doing something
different so they wanted to sell the
business and so I just stepped on their
foot I said hey if you guys want to sell
we'll do a deal and so we did and then
we did a bunch of m&a and you know pack
packaged it up and took it public that's
insane so the 20K you invested was the
initial amount but then you bought it
back for 25 and then you guys bought a
bunch of other Shopify plugins and apps
right yeah I think our total amount if
you look at it from that perspective our
total amount of investment was about 36
million so we we took it you know start
started it for 20K sold it for seven
bought it back for
25 did $10 million or so of m&a and then
took a public and we optimized the
business and GR it quite a bit over that
year God that's awesome that's a that's
a that's a good Insight I mean I
remember seeing like the press release
for Pixel Union and I remember you
talking about it but I didn't know that
you actually had to buy it back for more
than you sold it for yeah was 5x
basically it's insane um Sean where do
you want to go from here let's do the
the life philosophy so you said uh
people always suffer in silence what
does this mean yeah it's something Chris
and I've noticed so
we have this real culture of um autonomy
at tiny so we always say that when we
hire a CEO we leave them alone and
there's certain people who really love
that so for example often Founders who
sell their company to us when a Founder
sells their company to us um and keeps
running it often they sold because they
wanted to buy out a co-founder or they
wanted to buy out their VCS and they
want to operate the business profitably
so they're kind of saying look I've got
this great business I know what I'm
doing I want a investor who's going to
leave me alone I just want to buy out
these guys I want to buy out a
co-founder or something and so um
usually those guys they just want to be
left alone and we say great um talk to
us if you need anything and uh you know
sail off into the sunset and run your
business that works fine but often when
we hire a CEO they're used to having um
somebody who oversees them so like a
really active board or before they were
in like some big Corporation and there's
constantly someone checking in and so
they associate check-ins with everything
is okay and we don't do that we
literally throw people in the pool and
we say okay go and swim do whatever you
need to do and um and so often and
because there's so many companies
there's 40 companies now in tiny there's
always someone we forgot about that
we're not checking in on we're not
texting they've just fallen off our
radar or we think they're okay and so we
look at their numbers and they seem to
be good we assume everything is fine and
so we just say you know they're not
contacting us let's leave them alone
well so often we found that people will
fester in silence they will actually
assume that um here I am I'm doing this
great job for them and they won't even
do me the honor of picking up the phone
or checking in or um you know whatever
it is and and it's this I always I
remember about 10 years ago I was
complaining I was um I was hurt somebody
I'd sent someone uh an emotional email
and they didn't respond and my friend
says do you know what hanlin's rais is
and basically the idea is it's um never
a tribute to malice what can otherwise
be explained by ignorance or stupidity
right so never assume negative intent
but everybody assumes negative intent
you know we all know what it's like to
send an email that's really important to
us and the person doesn't respond for
three or four days you assume that
they're going you know [__] this person
or I'm G to ice them out in reality
they're busy they've got kids they're
doing their email they're they're behind
whatever it is and so I've just observed
erve this fact I don't know what to do
about it but people will always assume
silence equals
malice and then you have this other one
that says people don't change so you
first said people always suffer or
people suffer in silence and people
don't change this you're you're getting
a little pessimistic on worldview but I
agree with you I there's this author
called uh Robert Green he's got uh you
know 48 Laws of Power and he has this
other book book called human nature and
he's like why should you study human
because very rarely do people change
it's the same stuff over and over and
over again and then when you look at
their individual habits whatever they've
done in the past they're going to just
do just assume it's going to happen
again and again and again in the future
that's one of the best that's one of the
best books I've ever read the laws of
human nature by Robert Green uh I just
got the audio book and I just keep
listening to it every year it's amazing
um I I've just seen this over and over
again I find that you rarely hire
someone and let's say like um you know I
love to hire people based on scrappiness
will they figure things out will they
learn do they have high Pace I've never
hired someone who doesn't have high pace
and then coached them into having high
Pace right people either do or they
don't and the the only thing I've seen
where people change is it's kind of like
addiction you kind of have to hit rock
bottom right so if you're kind of an
[__] and you talk you you interrupt
people all the time and you always talk
about yourself maybe you stop having any
friends or you have an intervention your
friends have an intervention with you
maybe at that point you hit rock bottom
and you go I need to change I have a
problem but most people generally
continue on their track that they're on
um and I I don't know I I see this all
the time with with um people I work with
and especially people will not change
their ideas so if you let's say a CEO
comes to me and they say I've got I
think the best way for us to grow is SEO
and I say oh well let's think about that
what about XYZ opportunity I think we
should focus on PPC marketing or have
you thought about changing the product
in this way they will actually double
down when I challenge their idea they
will double down and they will keep they
will now defend the idea and as soon as
they defend the idea they will commit
and cons they will be consist what is it
called commitment and consistency bias
right now they will double down on that
so I've just realized like trying to
change people's impossible and at the
end of the day we're all like um people
are like elephants and you're just the
rider you know you just kind of go where
the elephant's going to go and hope for
the best you see a b guy a poor guy on
the side of the street begging from CH
begging for change you just say change
comes from within my brother change from
comes from
within I uh I completely agree with
people don't change I I had a thing in
my life where at 22 or 24 I forget it
was like oh this is rock bottom and I
had like I there was like a distinct
moment where I'm like I'm just going to
change that trajectory just a few
degrees and if I just keep going it's
going to make a massive impact I I had
but there's really only like I remember
I think two times in my life where I'm
like oh that's going to change and it's
happened but then like everything else
it rarely changes it's very hard to
break any type of habit or human nature
uh characteristic I think I would
disagree with that uh the only thing I
would disagree with is I would just say
I would instead of the phrase being
people don't change I would say assume
don't change as a reminder to myself
because the the problem is you're like
if you assume that people are going to
change because you're being hopeful and
you're you're going to make a bunch of
bad decisions because you're going to be
baking in change when change is quite
rare and so it's not that they don't
change it's that you should not be
assuming that they will change is the
the Trap that you want to avoid it's
like when you get married there's that
classic saying like you know don't try
and change the person that you're with
um and I think it's like be pleasantly
surprised like it has happened for sure
but it's it's really a Fool's errand to
try and go and change a person and also
uh it's sort of like ads people are like
oh ads ads don't work on me it's like
okay everybody thinks ads don't work on
them everybody thinks they're not
average I think uh you know the same way
it's like I think we think that other
people don't change but if I if I
separately had asked you you know like
hey you are you the same guy you were
when you know the last 20 years like no
I've learned so much I've evolved I've
just matured I've I've changed so much
and and um but we think other people
don't change and I think this I I guess
I'm a I'm a little more optimistic about
the change um although my sister has a
funny phrase about this she goes PE
people say that people don't change they
do they get worse and like and I think
that that's like you know more of the
how to protect your downside mentality
as you assume that people are not going
to change or it's just going to they're
going to dig in even further into their
current set of patterns um but of course
there's so many outliers that I think
you can only make it an assumption not a
rule um Andrew it was awes awesome being
able to catch up with you I'm happy
things are going well and you um you
said a few things here like I I I hope
the listener does this but I actually
have a notepad here that I take down
notes for like everything that we're
writing this profit first thing and how
much money leaving the bank I like I
have a note here I'm like [__] all right
I actually have to go and actually do
that um Moyes said something a few times
ago or uh and so did Patrick Campbell we
had Patrick Campbell on from profit well
on and I still have his notes here and I
had a meeting with my company afterwards
I was like here's a Patrick Campbell set
I just did a pod with them we got to do
this this and this and this is another
one of those episodes where you've
actually given me things that I'm
actually I got to go and run and like
tell my company right now this everybody
loves that CEO who comes in with the
with a whole new life life approach
every every three days because they
listen to a podcast like if I was in a
company I'd be like hey dude you're not
allowed to listen to podcast anymore or
go to these dinners because every time
you come back everything's
changing that is an annoying person
there's a good way to deliver it though
it's it's it's amazing how just a lack
of awareness can change the results of a
business right like as soon as I stopped
I remember I used to obsessively look at
my credit card statement as soon as I
stopped looking because I got too busy I
started spending so much on stupid SAS
crap or whatever and I think just
building those processes into your
company can make such a big difference
like it literally is those Sam you
described that thing of you know if you
were a plane taking off from New York
you changed 3 degrees and that was the
difference between ending up in Seattle
versus Tiana I think that same thing is
true in a company yeah and I think that
this thing might change the trajectory
of of a bunch of things that I'm doing
um thanks for doing this and we
appreciate it thanks for coming on man
yeah that was awesome guys all right
that's the
[Music]
pod